[Música]
comenzamos el espacio de medio ambiente
aquí en france 24 yo soy maría clara
calle bienvenidos mientras la mayoría de
los presidentes de la región estaban en
la cumbre de las américas de manera
paralela varios gobernadores locales se
congregaron en la ciudad de los ángeles
para proponer nuevas alianzas
ambientales y de allí surgió la
coalición de gobernadores una unión de
mandatarios subnacionales de américa
latina' que se propone luchar contra la
crisis climática desde lo local y que
cuenta con el apoyo del programa de la
onu para el medio ambiente por ahora son
diez líderes quienes hacen parte de la
coalición y vienen de países como méjico
colombia o argentina la idea es llegar a
los 50 gobernadores y jefes tribales
antes de la cumbre climática con 27 que
se realizará en noviembre en egipto
esta coalición de gobernadores se
inspiró en las acciones climáticas que
impulsó a arnold schwarzenegger cuando
era gobernador de california y que sigue
liderando desde su fundación r20 con esa
meta trazada la coalición propone dos
campañas la primera es rise to finance
para que los líderes subnacionales se
involucren en el mercado de carbono y
así recolectar dinero para el 2025 esto
con el objetivo de invertir en
conservación y para frenar la
deforestación de la mano está el plan
revista conservation con el que los
gobiernos se comprometen a aumentar las
áreas protegidas subnacionales en un 30%
para el año 2030 adicionalmente los
mandatarios que se unan a la coalición
están dispuestos a respaldar el programa
internacional rey esto sirve que se
propone alcanzar la neutralidad de
carbono para 2050 es la alianza más
grande que existe con más de mil
ciudades 67 regiones y cerca de 5 mil
200 empresas de todo el mundo
nuestra vida especial a la cumbre de las
américas natalia cabrera conversó con
gustavo máñez el coordinador de cambio
climático en américa latina del programa
de la onu para medio ambiente él nos
explicó que tan importante es el mercado
de carbono para la región los mercados
de carbono son fundamentales para traer
el financiamiento necesario para llevar
a cabo esa protección de la naturaleza y
esa captura de las emisiones de co2 que
tenemos la necesidad no vemos la
importancia de crear
normativa en los países de dar
responsabilidades a los gobiernos para
que puedan verificar bien que estos
mercados de carbono pues no solamente
traigan la plata a la región pero
también aseguren la integridad ambiental
y que verdaderamente esas toneladas a
las cuales nos comprometemos a capturar
pues sean verdaderamente capturadas y
las posibilidades de los gobiernos
latinoamericanos para financiar
proyectos ambientales son muy altas como
nos lo dijo alexis leroy si joe de
alcohol un grupo internacional con más
de 10 años de experiencia en plan para
reducir los gases de efecto invernadero
américa latina es sin lugar a duda la
primera reserva de recursos naturales no
contaminantes y al aérea de parís es
realmente este sector geográfico que
tiene el crédito frente a los que han
contaminado recordar que el 80 por
ciento de las emisiones de co2 vienen de
los países del g20 y si quitamos
argentina y brasil son países que
generalmente tiene un coste de
abatimiento que oscila entre 150 y 300
dólares y eso es la gran oportunidad de
américa latina-caribe poder basarse en
estos precios para liberar capital y
financiar la transición a una economía
sostenible libres de emisiones uno de
los líderes que más sabe de las
potencias ambientales de américa latina
está en mexico samuel garcía es el
gobernador de nuevo león y además fue
designado como el secretario de la
coalición de gobernadores entre 2022 y
2024 él está promoviendo una reforma
constitucional en su estado que dice que
los derechos de la naturaleza deben
aprobarse si esto es así sería la
primera carta magna- subnacional en
incluir esto en todo el mundo hasta
ahora solo ecuador lo ha hecho y como
país garcía se suma además a la
propuesta de la coalición de proteger el
30 por ciento de las áreas verdes del
estado antes de 2030 también está
liderando un programa para garantizar
que haya agua en nuevo león aunque ha
sido criticado por los racionamientos
que ha tenido que hacer en france24
defendió que los gobiernos locales
actúan más rápido que los nacionales
bueno muy importante los gobiernos
estatales municipales o también
denominados subnacionales pues son
realmente los que están pegados con la
gente somos quienes tenemos más cercanía
y quiénes sufrimos las crisis que
provoca el cambio climático la falta de
agua
las inundaciones
obviamente el tema de los alimentos pues
más que un presidente quien los absorbe
somos los alcaldes y los gobernadores
por eso yo creo que tenemos que unirnos
ante la falta de liderazgo de las pues
de las naciones de los presidentes
tenemos que no salir a decir si hay que
entrarle con todo al tema del cambio
climático y hoy con mucho gusto asumo el
cargo con ciertos compromisos a llevar a
egipto al cap 27 esta mención que hace
garcía a la cumbre climática 27 no es
para nada casual y es que desde ya los
gobiernos subnacionales de américa se
están organizando para llevar propuestas
concretas a los líderes del mundo pues
como lo dice sebastián navarro
secretario de ss 35 ciudades capitales
la solución está en los líderes locales
las ciudades tienen la capacidad de
regular el transporte de regular la
construcción son quienes se entregan la
licencia de construcción
una un porcentaje de la parte energética
los residuos los residuos así que
realmente en manos de las ciudades y los
estados está toda la capacidad
regulatoria para poder cumplir con las
emisiones como digo siempre no es la
primera vez
creemos firmemente que el acuerdo de
parís lo van a garantizar los gobiernos
subnacionales los gobiernos nacionales
ha incumplido durante 26 años y no
podemos seguirlos esperando france24 fue
aliado de cs 35 para el evento en el que
se lanzó la coalición de gobernadores
así llegamos al final de nuestra crónica
consulta en este y todos nuestros
programas en fra 224 punto com nos vemos
[Música]